there is actually no scientific evidence
that polluting from devices causes
damage to your eyes welcome to Haris
hobbies first of all what even is blue
light blue light is actually oftentimes
white and due to the high frequency
can't expose eye to higher wavelength
now contrary to popular beliefs the
highest intake a bullet is actually not
from electronic devices the highest
source is actually the Sun some other
sources include fluorescent lights CFL
or compact fluorescent lights and LED
lights blue LED exposures that you
receive from your device's it's actually
quite negligible and compared with the
Sun however it is a proximity of these
devices and at the time that you spend
on them that makes them worrisome but
it's actually not all that bad there are
several benefits as well
bleh boosts alertness helps cognitive
and memory function and elevates mood he
even helps regulate a healthy circadian
rhythm during the day not enough
exposure to blue light can actually
affect the development of eyes and
children early studies indicate that a
deficiency in blue exposure can actually
lead to myopia or nearsightedness wait a
minute what is always talked about
damage then well here's where that
originates almost all visible blue light
passes through the cornea and lens and
reaches the retina this can cause eye
strain
however the eye strain is not due to the
blue light it is actually due to
decrease in contrast some studies do
suggest that a continued exposure to
blue light can damage retinal cells and
lead to vision problems such as macular
degeneration but of course there is no
evidence prove this at least not yet dr.
Khurana now she has a different approach
to this he suggests that the eye strain
is actually less deuterated like in
contrast and more due to lack of
blinking she even goes as far as saying
that taking preventative measures
against food light can be more harmful
than blue light themselves she quote
says
it is premature to take preventative
action against flu like there could be
unintended consequences so it's actually
more of a catch-22 situation too much as
bad and too little is also bad the body
is all about balance so this doesn't
make sense
so what is the solution well contrary to
whatever you may read here or see it is
actually you that can choose the best
solution the best thing to always do is
simply listen to your body instead of
following advice from someone else if
you sit in front of the screen for over
eight hours a day
you feel no eyestrain or fatigue that's
completely fine your body is probably
just okay with that level of flu-like
intake however if you quickly feel I
fatigue and strain that it is probably
best to take measures to reduce Bullock
intake here are some of the most common
methods to reduce fluid intake the first
method is to 20-20-20 rule so basically
for every 20 minutes that you use a
computer it's just something that is 20
feet away for at least 20 seconds but if
you're using your computer for several
hours at a time this can quickly become
a nuisance some other solutions are to
use filters computer glasses or anti
reflective lenses but the most effective
way to reduce egg consumption is if you
can reduce your screen time overall
Lulla is essential to good circadian
rhythm and I development at the same
time however even though there's no
scientific evidence that blue light from
devices can cause damage to your eyes if
your friend eye fatigue and strain it is
probably the best to reduce your blue
light consumption everyone is different
and what may be right for one person is
not right for another one it is
outstanding that we have so much
information nowadays to help us make an
educated decision however in the end you
can avoid all that if you just simply
listen to your body as a result there is
no right choice and it just really is
what feels best for you so legs and do
what feels right
so what concept would you like me to
cover next measure post down below also
if you found this video helpful
then make you drop a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but till then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on next
one
[Music]